هذا هو عالم الموصل حيث
تقاتل القوات العراقية الآن من منزل إلى منزل في
محاولة لهزيمة داعش.
من هذا العنف في
هذه المعركة النارية الفوضوية مرة أخرى ، هذه هي
كلماتها ، دعني أقرأها لأنك تقتبس
من وميض برتقالي هائل
انفجار هائل فقط عندما تم إيقافنا ، كانت
أذني تدق الباب إلى MRAP
لا يمكن أن تأتي بالسرعة الكافية للجميع
السعال من الغبار والأوساخ
المتساقطة من النافذة الخلفية ، رأيت
عائلة تركض مع الأطفال ، لقد كانت
سيارة مفخخة انتحارية قالوا إنني لا أستطيع
التوقف عن التفكير في تلك العائلة
وجميع الآخرين ، فلنذهب ونعيش لنذهب
ديمون هؤلاء  كانت كلماتها أنها الآن
بأمان في مدينة أربيل ، العراق على بعد
حوالي 55 ميلاً فقط من حيث حدث كل هذا
، كنت أنا والمصور المصور بريسلين مع هذه الوحدة من
قوات مكافحة الإرهاب العراقية وما
حدث كان داعش  قاموا بنهبهم في
هجوم معقد للغاية على أحد هذه
الشوارع الضيقة التي كانوا
ينزلون فيها وتمكنوا من تقسيم القافلة إلى
قسمين ، يجب أن أقول إن هذه هي التجربة الأكثر
فظاعة التي مررت بها شخصيًا
على الرغم من
تغطية مناطق الحرب.  لأكثر من عقد من الزمان ،
ما حدث هو أنه بمجرد تمكنهم من
شق القافلة - في البداية
بإطلاق قذائف صاروخية ،
بدأوا بعد ذلك في إخراج القوافل بشكل منهجي من
مركبات همفي و MRAP
بدءًا من كلا الطرفين والتحرك نحو
تلك التي كانت في منتصف التأثير
الجنود وأخرجونا في النهاية من
سياراتنا إلى الشوارع
وإلى المباني وضعوا
القوات والمواقع الأكثر ضعفًا
لأن مقاتلي داعش في ذلك الوقت كانوا
يتحركون ويهاجمون المباني
التي كانت القوات تؤويها في
نهاية فترة طويلة جدًا.  ساعات
خلاصة القول أننا كنا محاصرين
بحوالي 22 جنديًا جريحًا
ستة لم يصابوا بجروح
نقطة في صباح بابي
وهذا على الرغم من حقيقة أن الوحدة
كانت تستدعي مرارًا وتكرارًا للحصول على دعم ،
لم يأت أي منهم يقول إن
الذخيرة كانت تنفد ،
وهذا هو مدى قرب مقاتلي داعش
من المبنى الذي يقع خلفه مباشرة.
حيث قضينا جميعًا الليلة
مع عائلة عراقية ، دمرت غارة جوية
المبنى الذي يقع خلفنا مباشرة ،
اكتشفنا لاحقًا أن ثمانية من
مقاتلي داعش كانوا هناك في وقت من الأوقات ،
وكان هناك مقاتلو داعش على السطح
المجاور مباشرةً يلقون قنابل يدوية على
الفناء الذي أصاب المزيد
من الجنود الذين كنا معهم كانوا
يصرخون على كل من يستطيع المشي حتى
الجرحى في إحدى ذراعيه
ويحملون أسلحتهم في الذراع الأخرى
ليصعدوا إلى السطح ويدافعوا عن هذا
الموقف.  لا يمكن
الوصول بشكل جيد بناءً على ما قيل
لنا إن الوحدات التي كان من المفترض أن
تأتي حيث تعثرت التعزيزات أيضًا
بسبب الاشتباكات التي
خضعت لها  مع داعش وهذا
يوضح فقط التحديات التي
سيواجهها العراقيون وهم
يحاولون تطهير ثاني أكبر مدينة في العراق